what you think of when you think of like
like the man pays for everything he he
leads you follow like that sort of thing
do you want me to answer that
um yes yeah why don't we start yeah and
then go around go ahead sorry
um
I I guess yes in some aspects like he
would lead and I would follow
um he paid
yeah he paid for everything on this like
I offered and said oh I've got it this
time
um that's I guess that's as traditional
because we didn't live together and
honestly we weren't married so okay okay
what about you
I don't think I have been in a
traditional relationship as such like it
was all very 50 50. he didn't really
lead much so yeah I don't think I have
no okay
no never been a traditional relationship
um yes so I'm married and
um I hesitate because we have a blended
family so it's not traditional in a
sense of like nuclear uh we got together
and had babies
um but we had children before we got
together and got married and now we're a
blended family but um in a sense of like
roles
um yes I am I am a traditional wire
and yeah I follow his lead and yeah
essentially he leaves the family
um I've been married before so I'm
divorced but I wasn't in a traditional
marriage or relationship
what made it not traditional
um I guess I was in my
masculine energy and
I
I was
doing everything essentially and he was
um
not really
the man that I I want
um that I now want you know after some
searching and understanding what my role
is as a woman what I would ideally like
from a man and what they want from women
more importantly
um so yeah that's what when you say in
your masculine what do you mean by that
um so I made the decisions for the
family oh okay
um financially
and more
um just everything really I just kind of
felt like
uh I mean I don't want to be too
disrespectful here because you know he's
the father of my kid and
um there's certain boundaries that you
don't talk about on there but
I I was in my masculine energy okay okay
go ahead
um
I think to an extent my relationship was
quite traditional but I think when it
comes to like personality and stuff I
think I was more of the domineering
character compared to him so I would say
in that sense I kind of witnessed that I
was more of the leader than he was and I
think that's probably why like things
didn't really work out between us but
yeah
um
auntie I don't think
relationship I mean now they hear it
perfect previous relationship I've tried
to make them lead and they have been
able to so I just had to go
you just forcing them to leave because
some men just don't want to lead someone
just don't know how to lead or they
can't yeah the one I've got now he can
he does
so for the girls that's sad because I
think you two said you've never been in
a traditional relationship do you guys
enjoy did you enjoy being in a more
modern relationship
do you want to answer that first
definitely not no I'm very I'm quite old
school even I'm young like I've got
quite old soul and I've always wanted
you know just to be one man for my whole
life and
it just wasn't that he wasn't giving me
that he wasn't really at the beginning
he was putting in a lot of effort but
towards the end it wasn't really there
and that's why I probably ended
what was what was the question again
what was it like being in a modern
relationship did you enjoy it
and is that something you'd want in the
future sorry I think these questions
elements of it I enjoyed
however
I don't know I feel like um so my
biggest fear my biggest fear is
financially depending on somebody
but it's my it terrifies me I never ever
ever want to come on a home with someone
I never won a CO in a business with
someone I never want to be financially
tied to a man because I've seen so many
women in my life be absolutely dictated
financially by men there's no hate on
men men are wonderful I know some
amazing men but no one's ever made me
feel safe enough to embrace my feminine
side with a man
which is why
I've always had my own businesses I have
my own car
getting emotional yeah I can hear it
yeah
I went through something really wild
recently
my ex committed identity of theft fraud
against me with his mum
that's what my EP is about
I'm not even using that as an excuse to
plug myself I'm just being transparent
because it justifies
I didn't trust anyone to take care of me
I got this
and until I meet someone that makes me
feel safe enough emotionally spiritually
and physically
then I will consider being in a
traditional relationship
I'm good I'm not even crying thank you
thank you though thanks um
do you think that's going to be hard for
for the next guy yeah because it's like
he kind of has to deal with the mistakes
of like your past in a way yeah you know
what it already has
been hard for the next guy and the guy
after that and the guy after that not
that not that I'm you know moving about
in different ways but you know
I go out a lot I have a very social job
like I perform for a living I sing so I
meet a lot of people and I've met some
wonderful people but there's something
within me that's just like but can I
trust you have I known you long enough
because the guy that was with last time
was one of my best friends
and I knew him for a couple of years
before I was with him and then to do
that and other things which I can't
discuss I'm like who can I trust
so I can ask a question
do you at what point do you think you
need to do some healing I you know the
sound and I don't mean that
disrespectfully I hope you no
I don't take it disrespectfully the bat
the sad thing is I've already done so
much healing
with all due respect it doesn't sound
like it though I know I know what he
didn't have you done do you know I ran
to the other side of the world I just
got back from Australia I spent six
weeks traveling around Australia and
this is because when I broke up with him
after I found out about the fraud other
women from his past were coming forward
to me
messaging me and these are women he
smear campaigns saying that one's uh
used to beat me up she was a drug addict
she was an alcoholic so I blocked them
all thinking it was true and out of
curiosity I unblocked them because I
knew they were trying to reach out to me
and one by one they slowly came forward
to me with their screenshots and their
truths and their lovely educated women
and it frightened me because I was
sharing a bed with this person you know
I was living with him I was running a
business from his home
and all of a sudden I'm discovering all
of these things I I had no idea he was
capable of and they're such nice women
they're my friends now they help me
you're friends with his ex I'm friends
with them yeah
couple of them are like how do you heal
if you're friends with his past I would
say that because they justify I
understand and I think you're right
however they Justified everything I went
through was real because you go through
this thing called cognitive dissonance
when you're trying to break a trauma
bomb with someone and it's where you try
and justify their behavior but they were
really nice they were so good to me they
validated my feelings but simultaneously
they're emotionally abusing You by doing
other things isolating you like I think
that's what we do as women though we
come together and then we talk about you
know he done this she done that yeah of
course and then there's no actual
healing that's being done yeah so like
whether it's spiritually whether it's
mentally you know talking to a therapist
talking to someone that you trust
getting it out
and then it won't be so hard on the next
guy that comes along and it won't be
hard on you as has this been a pattern
or has it just been him I mean obviously
that's pretty far but has it been a
pattern of like toxic guys in a way I've
had some lovely guys and then some not
so I the others I think they were just
young I don't think they're bad people I
don't even think this last one is a bad
person I just think he's not
and it made you move to Australia for
six weeks and to use you I'm gonna be
friends with these ex sorry
okay I just I don't know if he's battle
he's just done well you know I know he
had borderline personality disorder I
know when I got with him he was severely
anorexic he had a lot of demons that I
tried to help him with and equally I'm
not gonna lie he helped me with mine so
so that's why I don't know if he's bad
or if he was just so he couldn't stand
the thought did you know there was
demons like early on when we were
friends no no but when you started
dating him you kind of saw a couple red
flags early on oh yeah when it started
interfere with my work so I'm assuming
that like you had have guy friends yeah
I'm sure would date you right
so so what made you go with like the
toxic guy over the nice guy it was
exciting what it was exciting do you
know what I would be so honest about
this I appreciate the honesty and um I
think this is when my growth period
happened I before him I always wanted to
be that girl that could be taken care of
be driven around in a nice car taken out
to nice meals bought nice bags nice
jewelry because I never you know I never
had a guy that did that until my ex he
bought me he did all of that for me and
until I found myself sitting in that
Benz with the heated seats I was like
I'm really unhappy because this man does
not love himself enough to be with me he
doesn't know who he is he's unhappy he
takes it out on me because he's not
secure within himself
and now I drive around at my little
Toyota Yaris and I'm just like you know
what this is all I need I'm happy now
I'm good
um
I can't remember your question no I'm
sorry so so you almost put up with more
because he was rich
I think it was more
I think at the beginning that enticed me
but it wasn't that I actually loved him
100 I love you you didn't love him I did
love him
you just said it was because of like the
cars and it enticed me yeah it enters me
but he didn't he didn't maintain me I
financed myself he tried to buy me a car
I said no try to invest in my business I
said no he tried to buy me a phone I
said no because I even back then I was
aware that if we break up you're gonna
turn around and say give me that back
now I don't want to ever be in that
position
so no you know it entitles me that he
could take care of himself he had all
these things it inspired me I'm not a
gold digger otherwise I would have
accepted all those things he offered me
it was more I was inspired by his
lifestyle I wanted that for myself
that's inspired by his life what does
that mean well he could drive that car
he owned that car he's younger than me
I'm like wow I want that okay so it just
it just I'm just confused because it
kind of it kind of is like you're saying
the same thing okay okay you just wanted
like the hey hey life really yeah I'm
not faulting you for it no you're fine
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible